Dick Enberg back here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you jack I'm fine Richie
listen I got my picture but I'm worried
about the context I want I want to get
get my pet giraffe in there but I did
from the sand well I thought you donated
that you're after the San Diego Zoo long
ago Dec right I did but it is my
favorite African animal anyway hey this
podcast business I didn't even know what
a podcast was no come on and and so I
the invitation was extended and and I'm
really excited the adrenaline juices are
flowing and we've already done Billie
Jean King last week and Vin Scully
tomorrow will be released and Gary
Stevens next week just prior to the
Breeders Cup and we did John Calipari
and Kentucky I had to go back there for
a speech and it's it's it's allowing me
once again to be creative and do a
little not only the interviews but I
call it the sound of success and so I
have an echo at the very end of each
show where I do a personal reflection
and then a sound advice I borrow some
great quotation that I've collected in
Gary Stevens episode it's a John woods
make each day your masterpiece and just
a little nugget that perhaps fans will
enjoy the sound of success the Dick
Enberg podcast available on podcast
1.com the app or Apple Apple podcasts
Dick Enberg joining me here what what
please make me a fly on the wall you and
Vin Scully
cuz I mean you you go back to the the
day's broadcast and get together here
locally in Los Angeles correct dick well
in actually in a way he was my mentor
when I was doing the angel games for
gene Autry's radio and TV station in Los
Angeles from 1969 through the late 70s
whenever I drove my home was in the San
Fernando Valley when I drove down to
Anaheim for a game who accompanied me
the Dodgers were on the road and it was
usually Vin Scully calling a an evening
game in the east and so I was able to
listen to the very best all the way to
Anaheim and he is the poet laureate of
our profession and 67 years it's just
incredible to think that a man could
extend his great career in
always at such a high elite level and
it's in our little podcast chat and of
course it could have gone on for five
hours yes but unfortunately even had
other engagements one of the things I
found interesting was that he grew up a
not a Dodger fan but a Giants fan he
would go to the Polo Grounds and root
for his favorite team and his favorite
player was Mel OTT and so did you talk
broadcasting at all she swapped notes of
memories I mean just give me one more
tidbit for well you know I was just you
know you you're flying the walleye
that's the way I felt as well just to be
able to hear him that mellifluous tone
of his and and I did find out a little
nugget that maybe one of the reasons his
voice is so incredibly pleasing to all
of us is he was in the barbershop
quartet at Fordham University who knows
who knew that he might have gone gone on
and been a great thing
baritone what was he ejected we know
which one he well I'm sure a tenor
wouldn't you think Irish tenor Dick
Enberg joining me here on the Rich Eisen
show I'm wondering if you could give me
some advice if you don't mind dick
obviously you broadcasting for as long
as you did and then you broadcasted
sports in the late 60s early 70s but
there were really not many opinion shows
or social media with which to share
opinions that said in this day and age
the conversation of what's going on in
society and politics has certainly
pierced the bubble of the toy department
in the sports world and I keep getting
messages from people stick to sports
don't talk about it what was it like for
you late 60s early 70s turbulent times
being a sportscaster how did you view
your role in all that I think that our
role was really to call the game report
the ball and in fact in 1969 when Bud
Blattner who is the angel announcer left
to join the Kansas City Royals in their
initial year and I prepared in spring
training and I was ready to do my first
game nervously at Anaheim Stadium my
first major league game and Fred Haney
was the general manager of the Angels at
the time and he came into the booth
about an hour before the start of the
and he said I respect this is your
office M burg I've been listening to you
in the spring you're going to be fine
just want to give you one piece of
advice and then I'll leave the advice is
report the ball and he left and he never
came back to the booth the rest of the
year course Heaney was a broadcaster
himself during the World War two I
listened to him doing Hollywood stars
and LA Angels Pacific Coast League games
and it really goes all the way back to
Kennesaw Mountain Landis that he didn't
want anyone giving opinions he didn't
want you to say during of course I think
this will happen or I hope this will
happen I wonder why that didn't happen
and of course we've grown tremendously
from there and but I I then without
putting my head in the sand if I there
was a bad play or a bad moment I was
honest about it but I didn't seek it out
I didn't feel my role was to be
investigative I knew a player was out I
saw him in the bar the night before and
he boots the ball I'm not going to say
if he had gotten into his room before
2:00 in the morning maybe he would have
seen that ball better I didn't feel that
was my role and I think there's a purity
about the goodness of the game and
there's so much interrogation
investigation so many people trying to
dig away at the veneer of the athlete
and of the sport and tying it in with
the incredible politics of our times
that I think it's refreshing when we
don't go in that direction and maybe
that's my cop-out but I've always tried
to look at the very positive of sports
and 95 people say well what about the
athletes I said ninety-five percent of
those that I've met I wish there were
neighbors they're great the headlines go
to the five percent and I just assumed
they live in another neighborhood what
do you think John Wooden would have
thought of what's going on in the NFL
with kneeling national anthem and things
of that nature what is that oh I thought
about that rich and of course I did
their games for nine years and other
than my own father John Wooden is the
greatest man I've ever known
I think he would have allowed his
players to make their decision I you
know it's hard to transfer what he would
dealt with Bill Walton during the
Vietnam War and Walton going into
Westwood and lying down on the street
and protest with other students because
of the war
and it did indeed have impact didn't it
and but on the other hand coach wood and
said you have the right to express
yourself in any way you want but when
you put that UCLA uniform on here are
the rules and and I respect it if you
don't want to abide by them we'll find
you a couple of nice seats right there
at courtside and I hope you'll root for
your teammates today it's so much more
complicated and I asked Calipari in in
my podcast interview with him and he
basically he circled the wagons on his
answer but what I received from it is
that he has to respect their feelings
and he has to respect the university and
respect our society and you have to come
up with a common common agreement and I
think that's that's the real issue here
that does it really I mean I was
listening to the tail end of your past
discussion with the gentleman it is all
of this accomplishing anything at this
point are we really did we have a the
target that we're trying to shoot for
and to improve upon or is it just a lot
of good publicity and I hope I hope that
it will involve and evolve into
something really positive for our
country I it's tough for me I want to
stand and put my hand over my heart I
respect our flag and those who are they
really disrespecting it or are they just
trying to make their statement and this
is the great opportunity national
television or local television to make
that accounting of their feelings couple
more minutes with Dick Enberg podcaster
Dick Enberg here on the Rich Eisen show
Billie Jean King being your first your
first guest and you saw I'm sure in
theaters I don't know if you saw the
movie the movie about Billie Jean King
versus Bobby Riggs and the in the
Astrodome I'm wondering if you think
that she thinks that what she did on
that day still resonates and makes a
difference today yes absolutely
oh absolutely she feels that her stand
for equality and how it impacted
especially the women who cheered that
victory over Bobby Riggs many of your
audience you're older
listeners have saw that on national
television Howard Cosell the broad in a
tuxedo I believe I think he wore a
tuxedo for the event yeah and it's
interesting how they did some movie
magic to the Rosie Casals became the
color person at the event only because
Billie Jean wouldn't do the the match at
all if Jack Kramer who would stood
against women getting the equal rights
or equal pay or equal opportunity so
Rosie Casals was with Howard Cosell and
yet in the movie the actress Rosie
Casals is standing with Howard Cosell
and it's Cosell from the actual telecast
I would it's amazing how that what
they've done in blending in the actual
event the actual play with the the
actresses and the actor who both you
know the acting is fantastic I would
recommend the movie and one of the
things that I wanted to ask Billie Jean
even before I saw the movie is why when
she became divorced and became involved
with her gay partner and they handled
that sometimes in a steamy manner why
didn't she go back to her maiden name
she was Billie Jean Moffitt when I first
interviewed her after winning Wimbledon
in 1966 and and she said I just I'd like
the name Billie Jean King my husband
Larry King not the talk master Larry
King Larry King said why don't you go
back and take your maiden name she's no
I want to keep King it's kind of
interesting that their relationship I
think one of the beautiful aspects of
the movie is revealing how Larry King I
can't even imagine what would happen to
me if I discovered that all of a sudden
my wife not only didn't love me but love
the another woman and yet he has
maintained a close friendship and to
this day Billie Jean King is the
godparents of Larry King's children with
another marriage
Wow unbelievable dick III encourage
everybody to get sound of success to
Dick Enberg podcast on podcast one I
miss your voice on big games dick I'm
not gonna lie so I'm glad you're
podcasting you're very kind
send me some notes I could use the phone
dad look here oh yeah okay I'll do that
I'll do that as soon as I'm off the air
dick thanks for calling in truly all
right oh my thanks there you go dick
ever the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you liked
some of that get some more of that on
the Rich Eisen show app follow all the
information you see right here on the
Rich Eisen show